i watched eight for silver
last night and i was thoroughly
engrossed it is a very good film
um yeah and it's and that's the thing i
want to emphasize it's a film
you know the filmmaking on this one is
uh
is real good shawn did a great job sean
knocked it out of the park in my opinion
um and it i it's him and i
kind of geeked out on on the phone after
i'd seen it
um just because
you know like it's the film it's it
looks like a film that
um i loved when i first wanted to become
an
actor you know like watching all those
independent films
uh that i kind of grew up on uh you know
like
a cat's a betty's look but it's now a
horror film like it just had that old
school
really elegant beautiful cinematography
throughout
it's it's gorgeously shot i completely
agree so since we have some extra time i
wanted to ask a few other things
uh and i'm gonna start with the first
two questions i've been asking everybody
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
um
gosh um i would love to have been on
like breaking bad
um far to go
uh
what is oh those are both good
yeah they're not yeah those those are
good
you know um what what movie do you think
you've seen the most
uh probably tombstone um
just because we've watched it for about
four
weeks straight on on like a
winter out of school thing where there's
just too much snow and we just cranked
this one movie
non-stop where we were basically
mimicking the characters word for word
uh probably tombstone uh yeah
you've had a lot of success the last few
years as an actor
booking projects and i'm just curious as
uh
when did you feel like you made it as a
working actor
that like this is gonna be your career
you know what i mean
yeah absolutely yeah i mean i i don't
feel like you ever
i know that you know this too like you i
don't think you ever feel that way
either i i think i'm eternally
chasing the the epic performance
um or just great performances i'll
always be doing that chasing that but
you know before narcos i i then like
worked with
soderberg and fincher and scott
frank i think um but i was broke man
um you know and i don't think money
defines anything but you know i
i was really when i first started acting
i said i'd give myself two years to do
this
and um and that went well but
it at a certain point even after working
a lot
i was extremely frustrated because i was
still
you know really struggling to get by
and um and that creates and it's all
great it creates a great hunger in you
but
i really noticed it after narcos um
i noticed uh everything kind of slightly
elevate
or cross into another tear if if you
want to talk that way
because i i did want to bring up narcos
i mean i'm a huge fan of that series
and what do you think it is about narcos
that is so makes it so popular around
the world
even when it switches because the cast
keeps switching they keep on dealing
with different things
yet it's it's a huge hit for netflix
right well you know i
first of all it's an international story
um
it's a it has such mythology to
uh escobar he's he's the godfather and
the sort of kingpin
kingpin that you know sprouted all those
you know schizophrenic cells in in
mexico that
in modern day we're dealing with um
is kismik you know like el chapo i think
escaped on the day we released
is either season one or season two and
there's just so many things that just
kind of
integrated into it and i think also
netflix was not in central america or
south america
uh at all so that
[Music]
to show that up um
netflix in that and you know in that
region of the world
so there's a there's a couple things and
i think it's so interactive too in a way
because unless you're bilingual you're
you're really
engrossed in the story because you're
having to keep up and read
and then you know follow along when
you're in your native language so
yeah i think there's a lot of things
working for it
uh you mentioned fincher and obviously
i'm a huge fincher fan what do you
remember from making gone girl
like early in your career yeah i think i
lost a lot of that was the set that like
a lot of
um anxiety that comes with performing
kind of went away um
just because i mean this is to to
david's
benefit to what he does really well and
he gets
great performances out of uh you know
pretty well known that he does a lot of
takes so
after you know on
you've been in independent films and you
have one take if you get it if you nail
it then we're moving on
kind of kind of mentality you know you
make it three takes max or something
like that
so with david it was a great different
you know other side of the fence or
however you want to put it just a
different opposite
of getting to do that so much where you
just got
comfortable on set and you didn't feel
rushed you didn't feel
um pressured to to do anything you had
actual time to to do something so
uh that was an incredible experience and
growth
i i talked to you for the logan junkets
a few years ago movie that i absolutely
love just like everybody else
i don't meet people that are like oh
logan that's a bad movie
you know like it's universally loved
when you think back on
when you think back on the making of it
is there like a dare to you'll always
remember or is it
can you what do you remember about
making that film
yeah i remember um
you know because we shot in mississippi
new orleans new mexico colorado like it
was just we kept going north
as the film did um i will never forget
there was so many mosquitoes that
we had one of those um racket wands
and he just like floated funny
so this is
uh just getting eat up so
that was uh i i yeah that was insane
um but i think the final
the final couple days of shooting you
know uh
hugh really is he was really just aware
you can tell he was aware that that was
his last go of it
um and he was you know putting it all
out there so
everyone else kind of bringing up their
game so
it was yeah i felt like you're a part of
something that was
that was big and people appreciated it
and you just knew that this thing is
gonna hum
completely uh have to bring up shane
black's the predator
that's a movie that as far as i know and
maybe i could be wrong
went through some reshoots had some had
some stuff
what what was the movie radically
different
before you started doing reshoots or
what can you sort of talk about what
what did those reshoots add or
you know uh yeah
it did you know we shot i think they did
you know i don't know i could be
speaking out of school but uh
i think they shot everything we shot
everything in
daylight um either to save money
or to to save money
um and then we had
to come back uh months later like six to
eight months later
my son had been born by that point um
and we shot everything again slightly
different
in all nights so we did a month and a
half nights
uh to make you know to have this i guess
predator sci-fi thriller feel
which obviously the dark lends itself to
um
and uh so that was uh
you know so from the get-go everything
was kind of
slightly never really
locked in never really set in place um
you've got it's just a big vehicle and
once you get one of those big studio
films
up and running and just going there's
there's no way to stop it
so some things can run themselves in the
ground
but yeah that was uh yeah it was it was
uh
every every every film is different you
know everything you can never really
predict what you're what's going to
happen or
difficulties you might face but um you
know i feel like
ultimately you know the predator
the original was lightning in a bottle
and
um yeah people want to replicate and
repeat
and i thought there was a great story
behind shane coming in and
being in the first one and writing and
writing on this one
kind of bringing it full circle but you
know the
pop culture and everything in the ethos
is just sometimes you win sometimes you
lose
completely and i remember now now that
you mentioned it i remember hearing
about the
shooting everything at night because it
just the predator didn't look good
during the day it's not scary
i remember all these stories but enough
of that let's jump into why i actually
get to talk to you
um there's gonna be a lot of people
watching this interview that will not
know what eight for silver
is about so i hate doing the i hate
doing the generic
but uh tell people what the movie is
about
yeah i'll try to do it justice uh
everybody
uh for silver is an art house
our film simply put a little bit deeper
uh it's from a filmmaker named sean
ellis who
is is a real artist uh it's a story
about
a family whose son has gone missing
kelly riley plays the mother and
aleister uh patrice and maybe pushing
your name out or apologize
uh are looking for a son uh i play a
character named john mcbride who is a
pathologist
uh come to inspect what's going on
in the manor in the in the estates and
i also have been trying to track down
and find out what's happened to my
family
uh who are no longer with me so i
i'm coming to the family and i stay with
them and try to
to solve what's happened to their son in
doing so
uh you sort of uncover this terrible
tragedy
that's happened in the area and
therefore has placed the curse on
on the land um that's a good job of
selling it without giving it all away
the you know what i one of the many
things i really dug about this film
is no one is making stupid choices you
don't have like this random character
being like i you know doing this really
dumb thing
everyone's actually acting smart you
know um
and can you sort of talk about that sure
man yeah i appreciate your
blunt honesty um yeah it's
true me and my wife are huge fans of
horror films just because of the
adrenaline
rush so we'll watch dumb as [ __ ] ones or
watch you know good ones and they're and
they're really
in between right um and i've always
loved the genre
uh and there is always something
inherent to it though too it's you know
don't
don't go in the barn it's it's not like
that i think
it just showcases shawn's ability and
his sensibility to
to make a film because he's written it
he shot it he's directing it
it's really not out of his possession
he is um he's
you know the maker of all this so
there's a couple times on set too you
know where
you can it's really tricky like
you know is this going to give us uh you
know a technical advantage if we do a
scare here or whatever
so you know just leaning into sean on on
all that stuff whether
you know is this would i do this what i
want over here you know just
i feel like that's safe um
yeah in a sense in a sense but yeah i'm
glad you picked
you find that uh one of the things that
i think is really cool about this movie
is that the actual filmmaking and i want
to give an example and this does not
spoil anything
in a there's a scene in this movie where
sean
shoots it and he's also the
cinematographer writer director as you
mentioned he shoots it from a very
wide like a wide angle on this
um scene where you're seeing everything
in the distance
it's a wide shot right
and it's this great shot and in a normal
movie
you would then you'd start on that wide
you'd all of a sudden be
closer and closer you'd be you know
cutting to people's reaction whatever it
is and
as this big action unfold this big thing
you'd be getting closer and closer
there'd be a lot of editing this entire
sequence is being
shown in this wide shot from a distance
and you're watching
everything unfold and it's a beautiful
shot and
that is not the norm and that also
represents the movie
can you sort it and um can you sort of
keep
i think the entire film had that
approach
it's not the norm you know we're not
going to do the norm here
and it's such a great choice and sean's
consciously making these choices
and his actors are too throughout the
process of
making the film um it leaves you
the scene you're talking about as um is
a big wide shot with a lot of people a
lot of action going on
and you have so many little micro
stories going on in the macro that
you're
constantly tracing and going back to and
oh there's that character i'm seeing
them now on the bottom of the screen and
oh what just happened to them
it's um yes i haven't really seen
a shot like that in a while if i have um
so yeah it's i think sean's you know uh
he
he had the ability to to make a film
that he wanted to make
um and that's you know to ld you've got
to give them
um the proper props to that mickey and
uh
pete shalamon over at ld they really
were just trying to support sean and he
wanted to shoot that i mean it took
so much longer to rehearse that that
scene you know it took
an entire probably a day or two just to
rehearse so
you know and you're so what do you do
you're splitting hairs like we can
take two days and punch in punch in do
more setups more setups more setups
or let's try something different and
just choreograph
this this entire piece
completely um i don't want to give too
much away about the movie but
i do think that when the marketing
starts to hit they will reveal that
maybe there's a creature
in this movie there's something and so
um so what can you sort of tease because
i think a lot of people
like there's gonna be people who wanna
who are watching this specifically to
see a creature
attack people um can what can you tease
about the creature
um it got paid the most
[Laughter]
so if if you're looking to see if it's
legit
it's it's totally legit um
yeah it's creepy it's real they did
everything
um in camera so we
had an fx team out of i think they're
around
paris uh because we shot everything in
the wine country in france was
sort of central south france um
and so that was all built and my guess
the proper terminology is puppeteered
uh you know this anatronics
rolling creature um this demonic looking
thing
and then i think it was enhanced
in post by cgi rather than built
out from from nothing so it's it just
it has a different um
feel and realness to it i guess
there's i want to talk specifically
about a scene but i can't until the
movie's gonna come out
and yeah but it involves it involves uh
the creature and you and it's a
[ __ ] cool scene and i you know um and
you probably know what i'm talking about
um it's in a room and that's all i'm
going to say
um because i don't want to ruin anything
so
i'm just going to say for people that
can who are going to watch this if it's
still at you have the ability to see it
at sundance you absolutely should
but i'm a thousand percent sure this
movie is coming out
and at some point down the road everyone
will be able to see it and you really
should make an effort
moving on to the next subject um i
thought the timing of me talking to you
today was
really good because um you know they
announced something about a netflix
series called sandman
uh or my mistake what
do you know about it have you heard are
you a fan of
neil gaiman well i mean listen i don't
want to get you in any trouble because i
know that everything is you know
i'm not going to ask uh i guess i wish i
had some sunglasses man
um [ __ ] i had some somewhere
you know these are my logan sunglasses
um
yeah i yeah man we're doing it uh
we're doing the sandman we're shooting
it out in london
and um i play the corinthian which
uh is one of the uh
yeah coolest thing that's happened uh in
a while
to me uh to get to play this character
because i there's just
um yeah it's one of the good ones that
hasn't been done
and um it's like the last comp it's like
the
one of the best comic books that haven't
been made so it's um
it's exciting i think that sandman
is making it now is the perfect time
because of the mixture of the audience
ability to
understand all this the visual effects
being what they are
and having something like somebody like
netflix who is willing to tell this
story
in an adult way um and so i guess what i
want to know is
uh how did you get the role was it
something you went after like talk a
little bit about how you got involved
um uh
how i got involved it was a long
it was a long process uh i
had heard that they were doing it i
heard i mean i've heard over the years
people were doing it you know i think
joseph gordon-levitt was
even going to try something to do
something and that would have been i
would love to see his version
um but i read the script
and they're really adamant about
everyone auditioning
so i went in
i can't it must have been like
a year ago probably a year ago and then
and then i didn't hear anything for
until probably like
man september or something like that
anyways a long process
and then they the conversation just
started
and then they wanted to to tape again
and they wanted to
meet with neil which i was really
interested in doing and talking just how
the show was going to be done
i had some you know i
just because a project gets greenlit you
know doesn't doesn't mean things are
going to go great yeah you kind of want
to
suss out and figure out who who's
involved and how are you going to do
things and
what's the approach um and to make sure
everything lines up and makes
sense to to do because you you know you
want to
neil hasn't done done this for 30 years
so you don't want to
you know lead with the wrong foot you
want to get the ship in the water and
pointed
in the right direction from the get-go
because again that's something really
hard to reverse engineer
so yeah i'm really excited we um just
started
on london and we've got uh incredible
actors to work with and
to portray these characters when did so
you just started filming recently
yeah just before christmas i'm looking
at the clock
uh how long are you actually filming for
is it like a five month shoot and eight
months
until uh june got it
um are you was this one of these things
cause i
i don't know is this one of these things
when you sign on
that they say to you we have a three
season idea we have a five season idea
we
you we want you to know what we're doing
before you sign on because this is not
something that i envision is going to
fail
i envision this being a flagship
on netflix make something big so how
much are they telling you when you sign
on just know we have a five season plan
yeah i think everyone wants
a show to continue i think it's a
standard contract i think
seven five years whatever
we have talked about all that
i don't know if it will work out i think
it might work out in different blocks
of time but um yeah you definitely want
to hear
how you know how long something's going
to happen you want to have some sort of
macro idea of like how some
how long somebody's gonna last but um
yeah i can't i don't really want to give
away the details of
how long completely the i guess what i
want to know is
uh you've obviously read the scripts and
i'm curious
no i read them yeah yeah yeah i was
going to say but like for fans of the
material
and obviously you're familiar with the
material now that you've signed on
what do you think for fans what can they
look forward to
you know like is it one of these things
you know like i guess i want to know
that
um you know i i think they've done
a real you know dave dave goyer's on it
allen heinberg is our showrunner
um these guys know what they're doing
um howard our uh
directors jamie childs um
and um our other director of home i'm
totally blanking on right now he's gonna
kill me um
but yeah these guys are smart and
they're artists and they're craftsmen so
um
i think no one's leaving any stone and
turned on how
on what stories to incorporate and how
to weave them in together and how
to play this um
you know storyline through um
i think what people are just going to
see this thing
uh realized is is transforming it
is is really what it's all about
you know making it it is a
hard show to to turn into reality you
know there's so much set
building and there's so much
design that goes into this um
so a lot of people are employed to
to get that done so um and with
such grandiose sort of sets and all that
stuff you have to have a lot of people
making you know
coming to an agreement on decision yeah
i was going to say i
listen i know i a i know i have to go
and b i know that
i could ask you 50 other questions but i
want to know real fast um
what what can you say about this born to
be murdered which is another netflix
uh it's a netflix thing another netflix
thing that you
a movie yeah it was an independent film
that
we made over in um in greece uh
john david washington um luca guadagno
is producing
uh it's sort of an international
thriller
um it's it's really john's film to be
honest with you
it's film it's it's his film and there's
a
sort of speckled group of actors that he
that he works with because his storyline
basically is weaving in and out
um in and out of greece as he's on the
run
so um yeah it's really it's a it's a
really
cool exciting film and uh i haven't had
a chance to see it yet i think
um was waiting to go into festivals but
now it's covered
um i think it just went just it was just
bought
so we didn't get a chance to do any of
this stuff
[Music]
got it um i would ask you so much more
including bj novak's movie but
i don't want you to be late for your
next uh interview so i'm going to it's
going to be great man it's from
blumhouse
i mean he wrote and directed it i'm so
curious
yeah he's great he's got a big career
ahead of him
yeah i i again i could talk to you about
i had other things but we're out of time
hey listen sincerely congrats on
everything i'm super happy for you
and uh i wish they were doing set visits
on sandman you know if covid wasn't
happening
i would have begged them to see that set
uh all right
season two in season two we'll do
another interview
and i'll bring you along to uh to the
set of sandman
um just put a just put a good word in
for to ryan for me
i promise you i will um i'll tell i'll
tell him you said hi
tell him tell me he needs to know that i
say hi